We're getting our dipping pants on
and going condiment crazy in today's Food News.
Nom-nom, nom-nom-nom.
(audience applauds)
It's heavy. (laughs)
What is that?
Ross, we gotta do some wrist exercises.
I know, my upper body strength's terrible.
So Yahoo Life reports that our collective undying love
for condiments has everything to do with our memories
and the emotions that we attach to these sauces.
Experts say behind every condiment you obsess over
there's probably a fond memory or association.
Now Rossy, we have a plate of condiments here.
Mm-hm.
Taste one and tell me
what comes to mind first.
Well, I will say I love a condiment.
Wellington, my fiance, calls me "Sauce Mathews",
'cause I always have a dipping sauce around.
(audience laughs)
That's right.
All right, and so this is barbecue, ketchup,
yellow mustard, a hot sauce, a honey mustard.
Oh, that's underrated.
I just had barbecue and you know where I'm taken back to?
When I was growing up
there was a restaurant called Skippers.
Oh, I know Skippers.
Right, fish and chips and things like that.
Ah, and they had hushpuppies and Tater Tots and...
All of it.
And they had this bar where you would go up
with these little plastic or paper ones like this, you know?
And I was always in charge of the sauces,
so my mom and dad would be like,
"Okay, Rossy, you go do it."
And I would get cocktail sauce
and barbecue sauce and ranch and ketchup.
And I was so in charge, you know what I mean?
It was like the one time I had power
and everyone was getting a sauce that day.
And that brings me right back to that.
I love that.
I will say that this particular barbecue sauce
tastes just like McDonald's.
It, it, what?
Anyone?
Lauren, what sauce is this?
Oh, you're you're crazy, not-
This is Big Baby Ray's Barbe (laughs)
I'm so sorry.
Sweet Baby Ray's.
Ooh, can I see it?
Oh, okay.
You wanna see it?
Yeah, thanks Joey.
Okay.
This is so good.
(audience applauds)
Amazing.
Move these away from me.
This is amazing.
(bright theme music)